mit neuen schulden aus der pandemie fast
180 milliarden euro kredite will der
bund nächstes jahr aufnehmen
deutlich mehr als gedacht entsetzen über
das was hier zu sehen ist ein neuer fall
von polizeigewalt erschüttert frankreich
und der kampf um die kunden am black
friday befeuert corona die konkurrenz
zwischen innenstadt läden und
online-händlern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen an diesem
freitag dank dass sie dabei sind das
schon mal vorweg katja stresow ist auch
hier für den sport machen guten hand wir
beginnen mit dem enormen finanziellen
schaden durch die pandemie für
deutschland und den enormen schulden die
dieses land zusätzlich machen muss für
dieses und das kommende jahr sind neue
kredite eingeplant in einer gigantischen
höhe die den gesamten steuereinnahmen
eines jahres bei weitem übersteigt
gucken wir uns die details an
insgesamt will der bund im nächsten jahr
fast eine halbe billion euro ausgeben
mehr als die hälfte davon wird über neue
schulden finanziert fast 180 milliarden
euro das ist deutlich mehr als
finanzminister olaf scholz noch vor
wenigen wochen geplant hatte florian
hahn aus berlin
als die sitzung am donnerstag vormittag
um 11 beginnt hofft mancher noch auf ein
ende vor mitternacht tatsächlich tag der
haushaltsausschuss bis freitag kurz nach
halb fünf so lange wie wohl nie so
grundsätzlich wie selten aber
überarbeiten sie auch den
haushaltsentwurf der bundesregierung als
rauschfilter muss ich sagen dass
natürlich der regierungsentwurf so getan
habe als ob im januar diesen kommenden
jahres die pandemie zu ende ist doch der
kampf gegen korona und die folgen dauert
und kostet aus ursprünglich geplanten 96
milliarden euro schulden für 2021 wurden
so quasi über nacht fast 180 milliarden
darin auch enthalten eine generelle
corona vorsorge 35 milliarden euro noch
um verplant mit denen die koalition im
nächsten jahr auch kurzfristig reagieren
könnte was sie in diesem jahr schon tut
der finanzminister verspricht heute
hilfen für unternehmen die vom teil
shutdown auch im dezember betroffen sind
wir rechnen damit dass das nochmal eine
menge geld kostet eine welle von
unternehmenspleiten wäre viel viel
schwieriger und entlassungen werden noch
teurer
während die afg die ihm auch heute eine
einfache alternative entgegengesetzt
würde das ende des lockouts keine
haushalterisch dieses land retten halten
fdp grüne und linkspartei die hilfen im
prinzip für sinnvoll
die linke aber zweifelt ob das geld
reichen wird ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass die regierung noch vor der wahl
kommt und sagt wir brauchen mehr wir
brauchen nach schlacht nur in einem
punkt sind sich haushaltspolitiker innen
aus dem bund heute einig dass sich
künftig auch die bundesländer stärker
beteiligen sollten
an den kosten der krise erstens
schwierige zeiten mit großen
verwerfungen umso wichtiger zu gucken
wie all das von den deutschen gesehen
wird das zdf politbarometer hat wie
immer nachgeforscht matthias fornoff
guten da alle und jetzt haben gerade im
beitrag gesehen wie viele schulden der
bund neu aufnehmen will neu aufnehmen
muss wie sehen die deutschen das da gibt
es ein ganz klares bild fast drei
viertel der deutschen finden das richtig
so ok und dann kommen wir zu anderen
großen frage gerade in diesen tagen die
aktuellen core ohne einschränkungen auf
wie viel gegenliebe stoßen ja wir
wollten wissen wie der verlängerte teil
shutdown bewertet wird das restaurants
geschlossen bleiben finden 61 prozent
richtig kontakt beschränkungen zu
verschärfen finden 71 prozent richtung
richtig zustimmung auch zur geplanten
lockerungen an weihnachten 58 prozent
diese zustimmungswerte die waren aber
mal deutlich höher oder ja das ist so
und dass sie mir auch in der nächsten
grafik die korona maßnahmen sind gerade
richtig das sagen jetzt 50 prozent und
das sind deutlich weniger als noch vor
zwei wochen
17 prozent halten die einschränkungen
für übertrieben
31 prozent finden dass sie noch härter
sein müssten
im märz übrigens waren drei viertel der
befragten für die geltenden maßnahmen
da sehen wir also durchaus eine gewisse
polarisierung in den zahlen gucken wir
auf ein anderes wichtiges thema der
impfstoff der ja bald kommen soll
matthias voraussetzung für dessen erfolg
ist natürlich dass sich eine möglichst
große zahl von menschen auch impfen
lässt wie stehen denn die deutschen dazu
genau deshalb haben wir gefragt würden
sie
sich impfen lassen gegen korona da sagen
51 prozent ja
29 prozent sind sich nicht so sicher und
für 20 prozent steht fest dass sie sich
nicht impfen lassen werden wenn wirksame
impfstoffe verfügbar sind erhöht das die
chancen die pandemie zu beenden wird
dann im sommer ein normales leben
möglich sein
ja sagen 40 prozent der deutschen eine
mehrheit von 55 prozent glaubt nicht
daran
da wird also eher ein marathon erwartet
als ein sprint
also ein bisschen optimismus dabei aber
auch viele zweifel so sieht auch
matthias fornoff herzlichen danke heute
abend wieder das komplette
politbarometer gibt es im heute journal
nachher und jetzt bereits auf zdf heute
im netz
die korona lage in deutschland wird
heute markiert durch eine zahl mit
großer symbolkraft eine million
so viele menschen haben sich bislang
nachweislich während der pandemie in
deutschland mit dem corona virus
infiziert meldet das
robert-koch-institut binnen 24 stunden
wurden 22 1806 neuinfektionen gemeldet
das sind 8 142 fälle weniger als am
freitag letzter woche 426 menschen sind
seit gestern in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben
alles zahlen hinter denen natürlich
menschliche schicksale stehen
wer an corona schwer erkrankt und dann
offiziell zwar als genesen gilt muss
deshalb noch lange nicht gesund sein und
sich in manchen fällen erst sehr mühsam
den weg zurück ins leben bahnen torge
bode zeigt jetzt dass das
gesundheitssystem auf solche patienten
immer noch viel zu wenig eingestellt ist
es sind kleinste schritte mit denen sich
wolfgang schäfer wieder zurück ins leben
kämpft im märz mit der 54-jährige in die
uniklinik aachen eingeliefert acht
wochen liegt er im künstlichen koma auch
wenn es jetzt langsam wieder aufwärts
geht kämpft noch immer mit den folgen
seines schweren cupid 19 verlaufs
die gleichgewichtsprobleme werden
weniger die sind aber immer noch da aber
das stabilisiert sich langsam alles aber
es dauert wirklich das hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass es so lang wie das ist
statistisch gesehen gilt wolfgang
schäfer als genesen gesund ist er aber
noch lange nicht wie viele andere
patienten leidet auch wolfgang schäfer
gleich an mehreren folge erkrankungen
mediziner sprechen von post kurve
syndrom
während man bei der akutbehandlung von
corona patientinnen fortschritte machen
konnte ist man bei der nachsorge noch
ganz am anfang
genauso wichtig ist es für die patienten
die diese erkrankung jetzt überstanden
habe und an dem post kurve syndrom
leiden geeignete frührehabilitation
programme zu erstellen auch geeignete
nachsorge im ambulanten bereich zu
erstellenden da fehlt es an jeder
struktur wolfgang schäfer ist nach
langem krankenhaus und reha aufenthalt
jetzt wieder zu hause
ich bin gott sei dank eine kämpfernatur
die sich ein ziel setzt und dieses ziel
auch erreichen möchte ich habe 55 jahre
darauf hingearbeitet so zu sein und
jetzt möchte ich auch wieder so werden
um dieses ganz persönliche ziel zu
erreichen wird wolfgang schiffe aber
wohl noch einen weiten weg gehen müssen
vor zwei tagen erst hatten sich bund und
länder geeinigt den teil shutdown zu
verlängern und dann weihnachten dann
etwas zu lockern
jetzt gibt es streit darüber ob familien
bei besuchen der verwandtschaft über die
festtage in hotels übernachten dürfen
fünf bundesländer wollen das erlauben
auch wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
hält das für vertretbar aus dem
kanzleramt und vom regierungssprecher
kommt dagegen eine absage
welche kontakt beschränkungen gelten und
wo gibt es lockerungen die zdf- heute-
app verschafft ihnen einen überblick
über die wichtigsten regelungen für die
kommenden wochen wichtige entscheidung
im bundestag ab 2022 gibt es in
deutschen supermärkten keine
einkaufstüten aus plastik mehr aber
ausnahmen gibt es auch das sind die
besonders stabilen mehrweg tüten und die
dünnen plastikbeutel für obst und gemüse
zuletzt landeten in deutschland knapp
zwei milliarden plastiktüten pro jahr
müll wichtige entscheidungen gab es
heute auch in der länderkammer im
bundesrat und die hat anselm stern
endgültig beschlossen hat der bundesrat
heute mehr kindergeld ab januar plus 15
euro für jedes kind heißt eine familie
mit einem kind bekommt aktuell 204 euro
kindergeld künftig dann 219 etwas mehr
geld bekommen auch hartz 4 empfänger der
regelsatz für alleinstehende erwachsene
steigt ab januar von 432 auf 446 euro
jugendliche hartz 4 empfänger bekommen
45 euro mehr pro monat
außerdem beschlossen der sogenannte
grundfreibetrag wird angehoben also der
betrag auf den keine steuern fällig
werden 2021 klettert er auf 9744
übernächstes jahr dann auf knapp 10.000
euro und das gilt bald für uns alle
neue regeln beim ausweis ab august 2021
sind fingerabdrücke pflicht und ab 2025
ist schluss mit dem normalen passbild
die fotos müssen dann digital sein
das alles soll den ausweis noch
fälschungssicherer machen heißt es in
dem bundesratsbeschluss von heute
seit dem beginn des krieges in syrien
darf dorthin aus deutschland generell
niemand mehr abgeschoben werden
das will innenminister horst seehofer
jetzt ändern
er will bei der nächsten
innenministerkonferenz in zwei wochen
erreichen dass bei straftätern und
gefährden im einzelfall geprüft wird ob
eine abschiebung möglich ist das
bestätigte seine sprecherin die jetzige
regelung läuft ende des jahres aus
grüne und flüchtlingsorganisationen
kritisieren seehofers vorstoß syrien sei
nach wie vor ein kriegs land in dem
gefoltert und gemordet werde jetzt zu
einem vorfall aus dem iran der folgen
haben könnte dort ist ein
atomwissenschaftler auf offener straße
umgebracht wurden ist nicht der erste
fall dieser art es gab immer wieder
ähnliche attentate und immer war sich
iran sicher dahinter steckt der
israelische geheimdienst auf fotos und
videos ist der tatort zu sehen
das auto des atom wird
schafft es mit einschusslöchern in der
windschutzscheibe ein berater des
obersten iranischen führers ajatollah
ali khamenei beschuldigte israel direkt
und drohte mit vergeltung iran macht
also israel verantwortlich israel hält
sich an die traditionelle praxis das
nicht zu kommentieren also kein dementi
keine bestätigung
in der vergangenheit bereits hieß das
strategie der zweideutigkeit jörg brase
ist unser korrespondent für den iran
guten amt jörg wie gefährlich ist das
ganze denn jetzt für die region
das muss man sehen iran hat ja sofort
israel zumindest mitverantwortlich
gemacht für dieses attentat und
tatsächlich ist es nicht der erste
iranische atomwissenschaftler der von
den israelis liquidiert wird auch noch
sein vater jean d stand auf einer
todesliste und hat bereits ein attentat
überlebt interessantes nun der zeitpunkt
seiner ermordung nämlich kurz vor einem
machtwechsel in washington hin zu einem
präsidenten beiden der das atom abkommen
mit iran wiederbeleben könnte und das
ist sicher etwas was israel überhaupt
nicht gefällt der iran wiederum der
steht unter druck und deshalb könnte man
vermuten dass dieses attentat gedacht
war um die iranische führung unter druck
zu setzen die iranische führung möchte
dass die wirtschaftssanktionen der usa
aufgehoben werden und deshalb kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass teheran sich
durch dieses attentat womöglich zu einem
krieg hinreißen lässt die hintergründe
von jörg brase
vielen dank in frankreich wird ein neuer
fall brutaler polizeigewalt das land auf
bis in die staatsspitze präsident er
manuell marco ist bestürzt über ein
video das zeigt polizisten die einen
schwarzen musikproduzenten massiv
attackieren aus paris dazu christel haas
diese aufnahmen machen fassungslos der
mann mit kapuze wird von drei polizisten
brutal traktiert
minutenlang weil er keine maske trug
sagten dreckiger [ __ ] und schaut mir in
die augen und haben mich geschlagen
selbst präsident makro sei sehr
schockiert heißt es aus dem
präsidentenpalast
doch es ist kein einzelfall erst vor ein
paar tagen war ein friedliches
protestcamp rabiat geräumt worden
diese vorfälle heizen die debatte um ein
gesetz weiter an dass die polizei besser
schützen und gleichzeitig die
veröffentlichung von videos bestrafen
will die wie es heißt in böswilliger
absicht aufgenommen wurden
dieses gesetz tötet die freiheit und die
pressefreiheit es erlaubt der polizei
alles zu tun was sie will
ohne jegliche kontrolle der
innenminister unter druck aber er bleibt
hat artikel um den es geht bleibt wir
müssen die pressefreiheit gewährleisten
aber auch die polizisten schützen
es ist nicht das eine gegen das andere
boot holt tatsächlich ist auch die
polizei immer häufiger angriffen und
hass im netz ausgesetzt
die kontroverse um das gesetz geht
weiter morgen soll es in ganz frankreich
demonstrationen geben
zurück nach deutschland den
missbrauchsfall münster gab es heute ein
erstes urteil ein 53 jähriger aus
norderstedt muss für drei jahre und drei
monate in haft
er hatte im sommer 2009 10 einen damals
neun jahre alten jungen schwer sexuell
missbraucht das gericht sprach von einem
milden urteil weil der täter ein
umfassendes geständnis abgelegt habe in
der missbrauch serie von münster wurden
acht minderjährige opfer unter anderem
in dieser gartenlaube von über 20
beschuldigten immer wieder sexuell
misshandelt ganz anderes thema jetzt
black friday tag des konsums tag der
rabatte seit jahren halten es auch die
deutschen händler so und längst gehören
auch die zum black friday die bedenken
haben und sagen kauft bewusstein statt
unnötig zu konsumieren
so oder so ist heute aber auch eine art
kampftag onlinehandel gegen
traditionelle geschäfte rund 3,7
milliarden euro gibt es übers wochenende
zu verdienen aber immer weniger davon in
der fußgängerzone
gerade im corona herbst
das bedeutet ohne eigenes angebot im
netz kommen die einzelhändler noch mehr
ins straucheln
nicola albrecht jetzt mit einem beispiel
aus brandenburg es ist überall in
deutschlands innenstädten das gleiche
bild die geschäfte sind zwar geöffnet
doch die kunden bleiben weg daran können
auch angebots tage wie der black friday
wenig ändern innenstadt sterben befeuert
durch den online-handel das virus ein
brandbeschleuniger und genau dagegen
wehrt sich boutique besitzerin der
dienst sich linien aus werder an der
havel kreativität es in dem moment
gefragt der wille ist gefragt die
motivation ist gefragt und als dann ließ
wir haben den lockt den ersten lockdown
habe ich überlegt okay das einzige was
uns über wasser halten kann es einen
online shop obwohl ich das nie wollte
foto shooting für die aktuelle
rabattaktion kundinnen als models was
als überlebensstrategie begann ist heute
ein voller erfolg also die hanne und
stelle von mindestens 30 prozent also
die kombination zwischen online und
direkt ins tor
damit ist nadine zechlin allerdings eine
ausnahme denn gerade ihre branche hat es
in der krise hart getroffen der umsatz
ist laut umfrage des handelsverbands im
november um rund 40 prozent
zurückgegangen in den innenstädten
trifft es händler aller branchen 35
prozent weniger umsatz insgesamt
der verband fordert nun niedrigere
hürden bei den staatshilfen
und wenn das nicht kommt dann gefährden
wir hier über 50.000 geschäfte in den
innenstädten das sind modehäuser
schuhhändler sportgeschäfte die wird es
dann morgen nicht mehr geben doch auch
bemerkbar in der krise wird ein
langsamer wandel zu einem grundsätzlich
anderen konsumverhalten weniger und
lokal statt billiger und immer mehr
nadine zechlin schreckt das nicht auch
darauf müsse man eben flexibel reagieren
kleine korrekturen auch bei den neuen
schulden die der bund im nächsten jahr
aufnehmen wird wird ein nicht die hälfte
wie ich vorhin fälschlicherweise gesagt
habe über neue kredite finanziert
sondern mehr als ein drittel fast 180
milliarden euro aber das war noch
richtig gestellt
und jetzt kommt katja unter sport ja und
bei uns nimmt der wintersport jetzt so
richtig fahrt auf und alexander schmid
hat beim zweiten alpin weltcup der
saison und den sprung aufs podest
geschafft beim parallel-slalom am
arlberg in österreich wurde er dritter
traumbedingungen im österreichischen
vorarlberg stefan du jetzt fährt die
bestzeit in der qualifikation
im viertelfinale muss er sich aber dem
riesenslalom weltmeister henrik
kristofferson geschlagen geben louis am
ende siebter alexander schmidt schafft
es sogar ins halbfinale
im lauf gegen alexis pinturault
scheitert er kurz vor dem ziel das
rennen um platz 3 gewinnt er gegen
österreichs adrian perthel podestplatz
für alexander schmid das finale gewinnt
schließlich der franzose pinto gegen
kristofferson anderes thema diego
maradona vorgestern war die
argentinische fußball ikone im alter von
60 jahren nach einem herzinfarkt
gestorben
gestern wurde maradona nun beigesetzt
vor den toren von buenos aires gut er
nun an der seite seiner eltern
die zeremonie fand im engsten familien
und freundeskreis statt
deutschlands fußballerinnen bleiben auch
im siebten em qualifikationsspiel
siegreich und das ohne gegentor die dfb
elf gewann in ingolstadt gegen
griechenland mit sechs zu null
laura freigang hatte er entscheidenden
anteil am souveränen sieg der dfb frauen
der shooting star von eintracht
frankfurt mit einem hattrick in der
ersten halbzeit nachdem marina hegering
das tor festival eröffnet hatte
obwohl sich die griechinnen fast
ausschließlich aufs verteidigen
konzentrieren legte deutschland in
halbzeit zwei noch nach linda dallmann
und paulina krumbiegel zum 6 0-endstand
deutschland ja bereits qualifiziert für
die em 2022 das letzte
qualifikationsspiel am dienstag gegen
irland schnell noch zwei zahlen von
morgen 10 uhr 40 wintersport wieder im
zdf
katja weniger nebel mehr sonnenschein
das ist noch ganz gute aussichten für
morgen details gleich von osten telli
die kollegin marietta slomka hat das
heute journal um 22 uhr wir sind morgen
wieder hier für sie da und wünschen dem
namen des gesamten teams in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter dieses kleine tief
im osten europas lenkt die kalte luft
vom kontinent zu uns und so gehen die
temperaturen noch etwas zurück und die
gute nachricht ist denn nebel löst sich
allmählich auf
in der nacht gibt es aber noch nebel vor
allem nach süden und osten hin
man kann sogar glatt werden denn die
temperaturen sinken auf minus ein bis
minus fünf grad in der südhälfte
deutschlands hier also verbreitet frost
etwas milder mit drei bis fünf grad nach
nordwesten hin vor allem an der nordsee
morgen dann im norden weiterhin viele
worten nach westen lockert es immer
weiter auf und die sonne kommt hervor
auch im süden richtung donau kann es
aber dicht bleiben auch den ganzen tag
nehme ich dann mit nebel und dort
steigen die temperaturen bei nebel
gerade mal auf 1 grad sonst sind es elf
grad maximal im westen deutschlands
schaue auf die nächsten tage
am sonntag nach westen und süden hin
durchaus sonnige abschnitte sonst auch
mal dichtere bewölkung temperaturen
minus ein bis fünf grad das sind die
höchstwerte ja unter am montag gibt es
an der nordsee etwas regen bei 0 bis 5
grad
am dienstag kommt von norden neuer regen
auf und im süden wird aus dem regen dann
schnee damit ein schöner abend